the jurogan experience yeah that's what
i realized
that something was going on i didn't
know what it was a lot of it was anger
man i angry at what i don't know nothing
no specific reason i tried i mean i
tried like um
i've just done a ton of yoga i did oh
yeah yeah isn't that amazing for like
relieving anger oh you're so peaceful
after you get out of there yoga
meditation
i try the ketamine um oh you do the
nasal spray no i did the shoot em up oh
did you really did you do the iv yeah
you went to a doctor six sessions yeah
with a therapist in the room did you
trip balls
bro
dude there was a moment no joke where i
thought it was a tonsil there was a time
where i thought it was a tonsil a tonsil
maybe you are you oh yeah totally that
wouldn't be maybe we're all cells in a
tonsil
because you know how like an atom if you
think of an atom most of it is like
empty space
right
yeah just like a solar system right
maybe that's like the whole universe is
like an atom oh i wouldn't be shocked by
it and you really are an atom and a
tonsil but that the reveal on that
wouldn't be i need something dark i need
something more than that so when you
thought you were tonsil tell me what
what the experience was like okay so
they put you in the thing you're sitting
there in the chair and then suddenly
like um
you have your eyes closed and you're
talking with a therapist the whole time
during this place is he talking too much
no does he like me
[Laughter]
no i don't think he i'm glad you talk
because i don't it's hard for me
the most i've ever talked in my life is
a couple times with you
[Laughter]
back to kid i mean yeah
okay so i'm sitting there in the chair
and the man named john the serp the
sherpa icon you're unable to sharpen it
it's a little sharp i thought it was
like a counselor or something
i mean
he had a whistle around his neck so
that's the only one a little bit dicey
but
but it was sanctioned it's in a
beautiful facility it's a nice facility
so you go in they put it in you i'm
sitting in the chair is that a whistle
uh i think it would like it might have
been a safety piece he had from being a
child or something about he could have
been
i don't know lifeguard i have no idea
what his past was like
but he was a nice guy but he's a
therapist
so i'm sitting there and i start
dreaming you know like a regular dream
you know
i start dreaming a little bit i'm still
talking to him
and then i start talking about
being a kid you know i love thinking
about being a kid and stuff and so i
started talking about being a child and
then i started talking about my dad
and now like
the darkness is starting to have like
kind of shapes in it and
things are starting to feel that i'm
talking about are starting to feel real
like this feels real i'm sitting in here
with you and there's this table here and
this so i can feel this feels real
jamie's right there so things like that
i'm talking about start to feel it has a
feeling not just a vision
so i started to feel
i was talking about my dad and next
thing you know i'm spending time with my
dad like i'm
with my dad whoa
and i had you know and i ain't gotten to
spend time with my dad in 20 years
so like um
and i remember
i got to let my dad know that i loved
him i didn't know if he ever knew you
know and it was this crazy thing dude
i'm sitting there and i'm bawling crying
and like
i didn't plan on that when i went in
there
but it felt like i was really with my
like it felt as real as sitting here
with you
which for for somebody being deceased
and going
it was so powerful i would think that
that would be a hard thing to share with
someone you don't know
i guess maybe that's where the ketamine
really comes in and i didn't uh
it didn't bother you that you didn't
know and i'm okay with [ __ ] i shared a
lot of emote i share a lot of like yeah
i share a lot of emotional stuff so i
think i'm probably more prone to it
maybe than some people but i would just
imagine that like if you don't know this
man and you're sitting down it's like an
intensely personal part of your life
when he became the therapist became
just somebody i would check in i would
say john is everything okay am i okay
because i started to feel then i started
to slide down the edge of the universe
for a minute
what's that like
it was it was it was hard
it was hard because you don't have any
ropes or anything i mean you're out
there just
you're like
you know hope solar your solo hope or
whatever that guy who's who climbed that
guy
you had him on free solo alex
yeah you're like that dude but there's
no
but there's no mountain
no ropes no mount but you have i do
you do have a bag of chalk on your belt
i didn't notice that
but i felt like a cryptocurrency i felt
myself like going through these channels
um
and then i came back to another moment i
got to spend time with oh i got to see
my mom when she was a kid
which i thought was kind of interesting
wow
and just see that she was like a
happy child or something you know or
just i don't know
so there was moments like that for me
that were extremely
intense and real um
and otherwise there was a lot of moments
where i was just out of my
i was out of the chair i remember at
some points thinking how am i ever going
to get back into that chair
they'll never get me back in there i was
just so far out in my head how long did
it last
it felt like it lasted for about maybe
maybe 13 minutes but it was an hour
neil brennan told me about it first he
was the first guy to tell me about it
i'll never forget we're in the hallway
of the comedy store you know neil's an
intense guy yeah he looks at me and he
goes uh
he's like i was tripping
he goes i didn't know what it was going
to be because i was [ __ ] tripping
and it was uh for him it was to deal
with depression yeah he said it was very
effective wow it helped him a lot
i i i i took away from it if you had
like a some severe tragedy or something
like that then it would really help for
me it didn't feel like a long-term
solution it didn't help me with my anger
really so where do you think your
anger's coming from
i don't know man i don't recognize you
as an angry guy like you and i have only
had laughs like when you and i have been
hanging out it's always been just like
this fun
yeah i think i think some of it's maybe
responsibility
um responsibility makes you angry
yeah
i think sometimes i think maybe
i think i thought that whenever my life
got a like whenever i got more success
in my job
or something that i would feel
some
satisfaction something like you feel
like you made it
i thought i would feel like yes it's
different right and i feel appreciative
i feel happy and i'm not saying i'm
amazing in my job but i'm once i started
to have some success in my job
that i would feel different i see what
you're saying and i just didn't
i don't know you're still the same
everything's still kind of this you
still have all the same things you know
do you ever have imposter syndrome
i've heard about it you don't have that
i don't know if i do the the idea is
that you can't believe that you're
successful and you feel like eventually
the world's gonna wake up and go why the
[ __ ] am i paying attention to this guy
he's out here talking crazy [ __ ]
about his cousin getting bit by a gay
guy
well it happened on halloween
you know that's my favorite joke you do
well it happened in los angeles dude
still kills me if i could have been in
los angeles the guy was dressed up like
a baby deer and my cousin loved to deer
hunt that was the crazy part
so the dude comes out and he you know
his first instinct is to feed him or
whatever you know sprinkle that piss out
there whatever
and the [ __ ] dude bit him man
that's you know
that's newsom a guy biting you is it
newsome's fault i don't know
what that might be his fault i'm willing
to go with you and blame newsome
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify